Welcome to the show.
The current administration is likely to behave
outrageously all the way to the end of the
end, which is going to be Wednesday, January
20th.
And in the meantime, we're expecting a lot
of action in different ways.
Yesterday, House Democrats did introduce articles
of impeachment against Donald Trump.
This is the second impeachment against Donald
Trump.
And Trump could be very quickly heading to
being the only president to be impeached two
times.
This article of impeachment filed yesterday
is for inciting the mob that attacked the
capital last week.
And we now have a question mark as to what
will the next 24 to 36 hours look like.
And I'll talk about that with you in a moment.
Nancy Pelosi and the rest of her caucus of
the constituency of Democrats in the House
are also simultaneously working the 25th Amendment
angle, which again, I don't believe is actually
going to go anywhere but there.
They want Vice President Mike Pence, along
with Donald Trump's cabinet, to intervene
and simply remove Donald Trump.
Now, as I've said before, removal of Trump
via the 25th Amendment was warranted years
ago, and it continues to be impeachment of
Donald Trump again, is warranted.
And it is the right thing to do, even though
neither is likely to remove Trump even a minute
short of when his term will end at noon Eastern
Time next Wednesday.
But these are responsibilities that our lawmakers
have, not political calculations to be made.
And so I have said that they should indeed
go forward.
And the schedule, as we now understand it,
and because things are moving so quickly,
by the time you listen to this, there may
have been some modification.
The House is likely to vote tonight, formally
calling on Vice President Pence to strip Trump
of the presidency via the 25th Amendment.
So the process so far has been articles of
impeachment introduced yesterday.
We hear from Nancy Pelosi that the articles
of impeachment will be voted on potentially
tomorrow at 9:00 a.m. if Pence does not act
to remove Donald Trump via the 25th, which,
of course, requires the cabinet as well.
And if indeed that doesn't happen, then and
only then would there be an impeachment vote.
And so this is The New York Times is describing
this as a standoff between two branches of
government.
House Democrats are pressuring Mike Pence
to intervene.
And so that that's between the House and and
the executive.
And then at the same time, you are potentially
going to see a standoff between Democrats
and Republicans, not so much within the House,
where the Democrats appear to very clearly
have the votes to impeach Trump a second time.
But with regard to what's going to happen
in the Senate, and it has already been discussed
that there is, of course, not time to conduct
a Senate impeachment trial between now or
what is more likely going to be tomorrow,
the impeachment vote and the end of Donald
Trump's presidency.
That would be just one week, but that is not
a problem.
Legally speaking, a president can be impeached
after they leave office.
They can be convicted on impeachment after
they leave office.
But if you start that in two weeks or in three
weeks, what do you do to the first 100 days
of Joe Biden?
When we are desperately needing to accelerate
vaccine distribution, we are in the middle
of a disastrous handling of a global hundred
year pandemic.
And Joe Biden presumably plans to do quite
a bit in his first 100 days.
So the idea has already been floated of you
vote to impeach during Trump's term and then
you hold those articles of impeachment, delaying
the Senate trial for a period of several months.
We don't we just don't know at this point
what's going to happen now.
At the same time, you might recall that Donald
Trump and Mike Pence hadn't met since the
riotous insurrection on Wednesday and reportedly
hadn't even spoken.
We've now learned, thanks to New York Times
reporting, that Trump met with Pence yesterday
for the first time since he publicly denounced
Mike Pence on Twitter as the riotous insurrection
was happening.
Trump taking to Twitter and saying Pence didn't
he didn't do it.
He just didn't do the right thing.
And the meeting was reportedly more than an
hour long.
And it it you know, there are varying reports
from what happened, but it's being described
as a fraught peace summit where the conversation
is described as good.
But it's unclear whether Pence said, listen,
the pressure for me to use the 25th is growing
and you should do this, that or the other
thing to prevent me from having to do it.
Although every indication we've received so
far is that it is very unlikely that Mike
Pence is going to act in that way.
So for me, the real issue here is.
Not one of political calculation, and it is
not one of legacy for people like Pence or
other Republicans.
I've already said all of these Republicans
that in the last 14 days, 16 days of Trump's
presidency have come out and said this is
impeachable or he should resign or he should
be removed or this is now over the line.
These are not people who deserve really any
praise from us for what they are doing.
It doesn't take courage when Trump is at his
weakest and when much of the Republican Party,
but certainly much of the country has turned
against him and he's leaving anyway.
It doesn't take courage at that point to come
out and say, yeah, he should go.
It would have taken courage maybe to do it
before when they actually would have been
at electoral risk.
I'm talking about Republican senators and
members of Congress and others.
And at this point in time, it's merely a calculation
about self-preservation.
There are Republicans who have calculated
and maybe they are right that at this point
distancing from Trump 14 days before he's
gone rather than a day after he's gone is
better for them.
And that's really what this is about.
Even people like Lindsey Graham, we talked
about Lindsey Graham on January 6th, or I
guess it was really January 7th, very early
January 7th in the morning.
He he gave this speech saying we Biden's the
president and we must and we we can't hold
this.
And some people said, wow, that was a great
speech by Lindsey Graham.
Lindsey Graham is one of the slipperiest brown
nosers of Trump.
And within hours of that, as we covered yesterday,
Lindsey Graham was on Fox News begging for
mercy for Trump and saying, listen, Trump
did the right thing.
He lowered the temperature and he made a,
you know, a useful, productive statement saying
Joe Biden, well, he actually didn't say Joe
Biden, there will be a transition and I'm
committed to it.
Even the people that seem to be sort of talking
sense are really trying to play both sides.
And there are there are a few exceptions.
I mean, listen, Mitt Romney, at least he stopped
playing both sides years ago.
He met with Trump early during the transition.
It looked at the 2016 transition.
Mind you, it looked like maybe Romney was
being considered for secretary of state and
you went and had Frogs' legs or turtle soup
or whatever with Trump.
And then he wasn't considered.
And earlier, Romney said what was on his mind.
I disagree with Romney in that I think his
condemnation should have been much stronger.
I disagree with Romney in that Romney is still
a religious Republican and I'm not.
But at least my belief is Romney was telling
us what he really felt for years, whereas
with Lindsey, it's flip flopping constantly
and playing both sides.
So impeachment vote tomorrow at 9:00 a.m.,
the most likely scenario, and we'll let you
know what happens.